inside of which hole how would you feel
about that and she said I would be
extremely violated and I'd be [__]
pissed at you I was like oh [__] I never
thought
[Music]
and welcome back everybody to a very
very special episode of the careful boys
where we are currently Ryan we're off
the Record oh wow and it's a big one
because nobody knows where Joe is we've
just lost we don't know if you can for
sitting in yeah sleeping right now he's
really not here I called them let me
call them on camera call them live
but Joe has been giving Nick a lot of
[__] for being late so Nick's not saying
anything I ain't saying [__] bro
dude I'm proud of you Nick because it's
crazy like we all he he tries to act
like we start on time and [__] over here
like all of a sudden we start at like 9
15. he also talks about this place that
gets a real business yeah dude come on
that's why I'm trying to make my way to
top dude
you have them as JoJo in your phone I
mean he's not just late he's he's like
unaccounted for you this is this is a
good story I'll tell you why after I
mean not by not a good story wow this
guy's really just off the map right he's
off the grid dude you're gonna have to
he's off the Record so right now it is 9
27. usually we're we're getting going
about now so it's about right
under my phone it wasn't his real name
because back in the day you guys
remember me and Joe kept our ethnicities
kind of like on the down low right
because you guys and then also and one
of the other off the Record episodes Joe
talks about how one former JK staff he
would bring back is the klepto oh yeah
so that guy was a sneaker rooski so at
that time all of us never had that legal
term actual info on our phone that was
within because we didn't know if this
fool was going into the bathroom and
trying to unlock [__] or whatever so
this is just like a 10-year habit that
I've had uh that's why it's still under
JoJo instead of now that he revealed his
name it's not that well thank you that's
very weird
so he just left that I don't know what I
am on Swan would have been better yeah
that's a pretty unique name very how
many Jitsu Cowboys do you know at what
at what point when like Joe's like no
response like how many hours or days
goes by before you're worried
how many dates can I be honest or not be
honest probably three days it'll take
you three days of not being able to
[__] hit up your business partner who
didn't show up to JK news do you know
who Joe is yeah we do okay that's why
so like every other person it's like
okay if if
I can't reach him for two days he sends
me a picture he pitched a tent in a tree
he's been living in a tree for three
days I'm like he's living but you don't
have like before you have to like go to
like missing persons that's [__]
normal for him I'm just talking about
you don't have like a a secondary list
of like oh if Joe's not picking up for
like 24 hours maybe I should text this
person I have a question no because he
has crazy people around him you said you
said do we know who Joe is yes does Joe
know who Joe is that's a really good
question and the funny thing is I don't
think he does I don't think so because
he'll show up with this hair [__]
crazy right no shirt [__] a cape what
guys okay yeah but wouldn't sit for when
it's work right because you if you know
he's gone on not work week you know that
makes sense but it's like a work week
yeah it's like it's JK news filming day
when I first met Joe when we were
friends hanging out
pre-jk
I went to his house to meet up the Glory
Days something maybe the best days and
what's his house to meet up and it
sounded like he had a party over
he opens the door and I go inside and I
realize he was just talking to himself
the whole time loud enough for you to
hear on the outside
you know what I'm saying this is pre-jk
this is he didn't know he was going to
be on social media people are gonna know
him this is so there's no bit basically
there's no bit dude I would be [__]
terrified if I open the door and I just
started hanging out with him and nobody
was in the [__] and you thought it
was a party yeah dude I rolled up this
is probably 2003 2004. I rolled up he
has his inner black comedian talking to
his inner Vietnamese guy
what the hell and just going back and
forth constantly [__] this is during
the days where the monitors the back of
the monitor is still this big you know
what I'm talking about that's how you
dated Monger he just didn't have a
camera or
he is
he is one of the greatest actors of our
of our time yeah he's Daniel Dane Lewis
he's a method he sees you coming [__]
through the blinds he he gets his
[__] [__] going he's been playing
this character for a decade like the
prestige I'm telling you where Christian
Bale keeps his act 24 7. maybe maybe I
don't know could be
that's he just by the way said he's on
his way his alarm didn't go off uh so
there it is the mystery salt is it safe
than your phone is Joe Mafia Joe Malia
because I didn't know his [__] name
no it's not even Joe Molly it's Joe and
then last name Malia yeah I've said that
before I didn't know his name okay he
like you said they didn't say their name
so I was like all right he's Joe Malia
you know the time when you guys were
trying to hide your ethnicities and then
I moved in with Joe which was like a
long time ago yeah and I got his mail
that's how I found out oh I looked at
his last name I was like oh you're
Japanese I thought I thought you got an
old yellow envelope from Japan
with a little string around here
and the emperor's seal it came by Arrow
how did he feel when he found out you
caught him slipping
um I don't think he cared at that time
but he only cares if it's like public
but because like we live together and he
knows like I'm not just gonna go around
telling people hey guess what Joe is
what's the context behind that why was
he why were you guys trying to someone
during that time you got to think 2007
2008 yeah right where there's like uh
very little Asians in in cinema and
social media and stuff and uh there was
actually during the time where there was
more hate than love so now during like
all those whatever because right now
stop Asian love era yeah that during
that time what's that thing that
everyone goes through the [__] Gala
right when they go to the gala people
are like like cape yeah like Brett Brett
man Rock and Phil Wick oh Unforgettable
right right right right right right this
[__] didn't [__] exist so it was like
good contracts Koreans make it [__]
chinks right like Vietnamese make it
[__] [__] gooks or whatever it was
like that era forgot all about those
banners that's right I used to say that
so often and I forgot
me and Joe were like dude this is
[__] whack we should be together so
we're doing all these characters and we
we didn't uh reveal our ethnicity so
that we can kind of be she could be
Ambiguously playing all the characters
yes I see okay that makes sense who like
out of this group specifically if like
people didn't show up to work who would
you be most quickly worried about most
worthy me yeah me really right Ryan and
you I think you guys are super
professional always early I would be
worried about you I'd be worried because
you're not gonna bring donuts
both of you guys for sure you guys are
super on top of it all the time what if
I didn't show up
he can work his way out he'll be fine
uh Nick don't you feel like this is
appropriate time to set up some booby
traps for Joe yeah what kind of booty
traps we can set up we'll set it up in
between a bunch of marbles
he's even sleeping I thought he sleeps
here he usually does but where the [__]
is he ready maybe it's an anniversary I
don't know oh they're having an
anniversary I don't know I love that he
doesn't even know his anniversary either
that's the best part too he's like maybe
it is man it's his birthday he's like
you know how well I know Joe right so
yeah what's this [__] anniversary I
have no [__] idea he doesn't even
know I believe that too
oh man so what do you guys want to talk
about another joke
leave it to Nick can't have a half a
second yeah let's let's [__] you know
what's more normal about his anniversary
but it'd probably be more normal for Joe
to forget his actual anniversary got
together with Hannah and go oh my God we
bonded over Lucky Charms do you know
when Lucky Charms was invented that's
our anniversary
wow and they were selling so
well it's kind of crazy you know it's
really fun
obviously we're just talking about this
but the Discord just started up again
yeah patrons and stuff like that and I
sent you guys that screenshot because
somebody had wrote in the Discord
they're like yo so it was an ask the
boys thread for the patrons and the
question is yo so did Joe really eat out
a hooker's [__] or is that a [__]
very worried about y'all
yeah yeah that's really deeply concerned
for Joe and the things he does maybe
just considering eating out a hooker's
[__] I wish I knew what changes
depending on what the answer to that is
in his life
he's like come on no
would any of you guys have done that no
[__] I don't think so I thought that
was the incorrect usage well you
repeated the question what does that
mean that means no I was I was
flabbergasted at the thought of that I
just want to see what her reaction was
oh you know it must have been her first
that's that's what I really wanted I'm
one of those guys who's so straight that
you have to pay me to eat [__]
so straight
that's kind of the weird thing about us
always being bewildered by Joe like
can't handle himself and starts eating
[__] we're all like oh I would never
yeah like ew a hooker why no but I mean
I assume she washes the damn thing yeah
you don't know sometimes you might get
hot and bothered you might even be ready
to go you might see it and you just want
to [__] so you're telling me if there's
a bowl your favorite Bowl someone put
dog [__] in it and they washed it you'd
still be down to eat out of it why if
it's my favorite Bowl picture oh that's
true I think that's what the hotel and
Joe is such a cream pie kind of guy [__]
her [__] it's my favorite Bowl
I have to eat my lunch stipulation
I mean that's a big deal see yeah if
someone took a [__] you're that's
different though and your favorite boy
you're not gonna get out of it if a man
took a [__] in my favorite bowl or my
favorite vagina dude yeah but what if
the bowl what if the bowl just appeared
clean but it didn't it wasn't actually
washed it just had a dirt what world do
you live in my friend what do you mean
it appears clean what is the scenario
God took a [__] at it we're gonna clean
it without soap oh is this the new
[__] would you rather [__] your mom
or your dad no this is no no no would
you eat out of a bowl
that's the newest cold question for the
[__] hot scene but Joe is notorious
for his cream pie infatuation so like
chances are he's already with the hooker
that like probably has six or seven
cream pies left in there oh God left
dinner huh well God you're the one
envisioning [__] dog [__] in a
favorite Bowl I think that's gay sick
[__] in a favorite oh who does that
what's his favorite bowl no I pictured
seven different cream pies all backed up
in there dude what if Joe has a kid we
don't know about that's pretty likely
because we're saying cream pies do we
get demonetized for saying uh not if you
say cream and then pies can you say
serious
cream eyes pause for demonetization pies
that video clip that you took from uh
when Kazumi was here yeah why you
pointing at me like on Kazumi well
because she was sitting over here
dude you're looking like Kazumi to me
boy I didn't I didn't bleep out
[__] it didn't get shadowed or
anything no but like the way he explains
that situation so candidly like just
like you know you mean the way where
he's sucking his [__] cup that's not
very careful did you already know that
story yeah oh okay I did know about that
story as well and that and it was still
disturbing to her again and he's like oh
man because I was actually that's
actually like tip of the iceberg
what was it was more of like it was more
of like [__] Gastronomy or some [__]
like I think I think she's he sucked it
out put it in her mouth then she put it
back in his mouth and then it was like
he sucked it out and put it in her mouth
and she put it back in his mouth so he
just he just doesn't sing the first half
of the story no he said they were
kissing with it yeah no he says that but
he didn't say he sucked it out and put
it in her mouth he said that she kissed
him and then it got back in his because
he said that she put it in her mouth
versus he creampied her and then took it
out with his mouth and then put it back
in and put it back and forth all kinds
of [__] it's like a water park that lady
is crazy he put it back to the source he
took it from the source and he put it
back
in the reader that lady is crazy she
blew it back in right that was his
actual X oh no I think someone he was
just that was a that was a fan nice
that's the way I always been everything
it's always a fan that one particular it
was a fan plug that's a lot no I don't
know I have no idea but that's how you
know it Joe is a very giving guy he's
down for Life yeah that is actually and
knowing that he didn't want to do it but
she did so that's why he still did it
yeah he's a giver dude Joe's a giver I
think that's a purple heart I think I
think I'm maybe not a giver now
yeah you guys were in the same situation
what would you do
like I know a real Giver don't don't do
this [__] if you want to say your Giver
be careful yeah I know a guy yeah don't
jump the gun I don't think I'd be down
man not that I don't like that so just
sucking you off why is Joe sucking me
off
why are you saying it like that of
course you heard it like like Joe
Joe's sucking you off right and then you
bust in his her mouth right in her mouth
her mouth and then she really really
wants to romantically start kissing you
surprising she's just surprised she put
it on me boom right then yeah yeah yeah
you know the jizz is in there she's like
a [__] love you bro are you gonna
push her face off if she surprised me
and it's in the moment it might happen
oh
you sick little [__] eater
you are gay for yourself boy dude
someone likes to eat coming here
afterwards I'd be [__] pissed I'd be
like why the [__] you just bring that
[__] on me but what if she was like but
how come every single time you eat my
every every time you eat meat out once
you come up we can make out and I'm
getting my [__] juice in my mouth but
it's never a question what'd you just
say
something Mandarin talk to a lawyer this
feels like role-playing now I feel like
now we're gonna be like hey you want
some [__] for those steak and eggs no
because I did ask her a question and so
this made me go oh yeah I don't want
surprises sprung on me but I asked her
because one time because we our desks
face opposite directions and I turn
around and her neck looks so chokeable
so I was like Hey like how would you
feel don't judge me because these are
just raw thoughts right don't judge me
but I was like let's say I come look
behind you rear naked put you out and
then you wake up with my dick inside of
you inside of which hole or [__] okay
how would you feel about that and she
said I would be extreme mainly violated
and I'd be [__] pissed at you I was
like oh [__] I never thought oh
how did we get married I was just I just
didn't so aggregated aggregated assaults
like not I don't even think
don't kick shame at least you asked I
was just yeah I just had a question I
was like oh like why would you be so
he's like because you just it just got
sprung on me because you left her I'm
like so spring in on people is not a
good thing because the brain damage risk
scientific your [__] neck is exposed
she comes and rear naked you you pass
out next time you wake up with a dick in
you yes you're not a dildo a dildo up
your ass
I think I would be more like this is a
strange scenario first before like
science hat yes see see I'm not gonna
bark for a long time yeah I would be the
Hat with the propeller so science would
go before violated yeah when you have a
dick before the that yeah he'll probably
be in the shower like two days later and
be like yo I think that was fun try my
hits them after yo did I get railed in
the ass yeah dude what the [__] I lost
my virginity without my permission yeah
dude that's kind of messed up and then
you would never even reach anger it
would just go straight to pleasure or
something like pledge I never said
anything about pleasure well you know
you didn't even say anything about
violation I said I would be validated
after that three processes yeah first
I'm like whoa what's what is going on
what how long is after though because
you're getting railed right now oh I'm
getting a rail I didn't know I thought
you just you just said I woke up with it
like like a butt plug like it was stuck
in there oh was that your savior
scenario you're just there with a penis
inside her yeah I'm just in there like
this you're not doing anything yeah you
just you made her pass out just so you
stick your dick in and not doing it I'm
not thrusting I'm just waiting for her
to wake up to see what's going on just
to use her like a pocket
yeah just to put it away yeah
like a koozie
you don't have these kind of
conversations with Nina I don't even
have these kinds of imaginations oh
because your neck was looking so jokable
don't judge me just my mind thinking
like
raw thoughts you know just going back
and how long did that conversation last
with you that's it we went back to
working
and then did you did you I just went
straight back and then you're just like
do you feel safe around me
[Laughter]
she's like it's normal and everything is
good the [__] is wrong she's looking
over her shoulder every five minutes
dude she's countering to nothing every
now and then all I gotta say in this
room can has a really exposed neck
[Laughter]
I thought they were the sickest thing I
had ever saw even this thing where you
can look over oh that thing was tight
you ever had that yeah what the [__]
copy people's paper but oh like a
periscope yeah it's like a pair of
anything from the Spy Store there used
to be spy stores in those random like
plazas and strip malls they don't have
them no more like kids spy stores are
like spy stores I don't know oh like kid
spice stores but they had they had adult
[__] too like under the glass though in
in Cerritos remember with luck where
Lucky's is oh but then now it's a
Seafood City there was a spy store in
that strip mall where they would have
like spray cans but then you un you
unscrew it and you can store [__]
underneath is that where Goldilocks used
to be Yeah Yeah Yeah by microfilm you
get all your microphone there I used to
get all my microphone there what's
microphone it's like [__] and spy movies
I don't know
yeah but that's when small cameras were
novelty yeah yeah remember it was like
you couldn't just get them anywhere
small kids yeah they even had the camera
built into the like
yeah or like in a lipstick or a pen or
something they have cameras in like uh
sockets like you know like if you plug
in yeah but you know how there's a
little screw you can have a camera there
but it's powered yeah you get that
little mirror on a stick so you could
bend a bean somebody's calling you
nice scammer is that JoJo
scammer I'm just waiting for when Joe's
gonna actually pop in he's not we should
roll for that actually are we gonna
booby trap him oh he says if you he says
you guys filming are you guys filming he
just said that he's probably he's just
outside
[Laughter]
is he here
oh